was für eine pleite für robert habeck
die beliebtheitswerte des
bundeswirtschafts minister stürzen ab
eine umfrage des meinungsforschungs
institut in seinem auftrag von bild
zeigt habeck verliert 6 punkte im
politiker-ranking und fällt also von
platz eins auf platz sechs schauen uns
das genauer an für annalena baerbock
geht's nämlich ganz nach oben so sieht
es also aus annalena baerbock auf platz
eins gefolgt von markus söder auch erst
aufgestiegen schnellste mir bleibt auf
dem platz drei auch sahra wagenknecht
steigt auch von den dritten auf den
vierten platz hendrik wüst auf platz
fünf und dann sehen wir eben auf platz
sechs robert habeck für ihn geht es fünf
plätze nach unten er war auf platz eins
also vom ersten auf dem sechsten platz
vom sonnyboy der politik zum großen
verlierer
er wurde geschätzt er wurde gefeiert und
viele haben ihn schon als nächsten
bundeskanzler gesehen robert habe
bundeswirtschaftsminister
grünen-chef kinderbuchautor mister
popular wird immer unbeliebter über ein
halbes jahr lang stand er an der spitze
der beliebtesten politiker in
deutschland jetzt der absturz
platz sechs zu unseren
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck ist er
der richtige für diesen job ein
wirtschaftsminister muss ein bisschen
ahnung von wirtschaft haben ja ich
glaube hat sich schrittweise und sowas
aber dass ich jetzt unbedingt beliebt
gemacht finde prinzipiell dass er so
eine teddy bhc twitter hat natürlich das
schwierigste job im moment aber mit der
schweren statur
binnenwirtschaft hat da keiner an da
wird uns runter okay mögliche gründe für
die umfrage klatsche ganz klar zwecks
krisen-management er verabschiedet das
entlastungspaket drei entlastet dabei
aber vor allem arbeitslose und
studierende vergisst in mittelstand
komplett
außerdem hält er weiter eisern am
atomausstieg fest und nicht zuletzt sind
es solche aussagen die an seiner
kompetenz als wirtschaftsminister mehr
als zweifeln lassen ja ich weiß doch auf
dem wasser automatisch eine
insolvenzwelle geben muss aber es kann
sein dass ich bestimmte geschäfte nicht
mehr rentieren und wieder eingestellt
werden vielleicht werden sie später
wieder aufgenommen das kann ja sein also
das ist dann ja keine klassische
insolvenz besonders bitter ausgerechnet
außenministerin annalena baerbock
übernimmt jetzt den spitzenplatz
[Applaus]
[Musik]